ce nouveau point presse des républicains
que nous allons tenir avec lydia guirous
ce nous voudrions commencer cette
séquence par un rappel de l'agenda c'est
ainsi généralement on entame les points
presse jana qui qui se charge pour les
républicains
à la faveur notamment des déplacements
sur le terrain de notre président avant
cela nous aurons demain je pense que ça
n'a échappé à personne
une réunion de la commission nationale
d'investiture qui se réunira donc à
16h30 sur le sujet des élections
européennes
ce sera j'en suis bien désolé une
réunion à huis clos mesdames messieurs
nous aurons le lendemain à 18h30 à
nouveau rendez vous des idées présence
de laurent wauquiez est également d'eric
zemmour que nous accueillerons dans ses
locaux et ce sera animée comme les
précédents rendez vous des idées par
guillaume larrivé député de l'yonne et
secrétaire général délégué au projet des
républicains puisque nous continuons
travailler sur les thématiques qui sont
celles qui tiennent au coeur des
français
en invitant particulier un certain
nombre de personnalités d'essayiste de
penseurs quel qu'il soit pour nourrir
notre propre réflexion
le 1er février comment sera le tour de
france que laurent wauquiez s'est
proposé de faire à la rencontre des
français il a estimé vous le savez que
il était nécessaire de coller à la
réalité du terrain d'aller à la
rencontre de nos compatriotes dans un
moment de doute dans un moment où le
pays est en proie à une crise inédite
dans l'histoire de la vème république
et pour ce faire le président des
républicains entamera son tour de france
qui va durer entre dix et douze jours
d'affilée par une première étape qui se
déroulera à belfort et ensuite il
cheminera sur les sentiers de france
pendant pratiquement deux semaines
d'affilée donc on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler en fonction
du programme qui sera prochainement
précisées et enfin dernier point
d'agenda et je laisse la parole à lille
tout de suite après c'est le 16 mars ce
sera le conseil national des
républicains décentralisées comme le
précédent il se tiendra à villeurbanne
voilà donc nous aurons l'occasion à ce
moment-là il reprécise rats évidemment
les contours de ce conseil national il
sera évidemment question d'élections
européennes mais pas seulement lorsque
le moment sera venu
voilà mesdames messieurs merci gilles
les républicains toujours à l'écouté des
préoccupations des français est toujours
très concentré sur les préoccupations et
la détresse des classes moyennes qui
supportent la plus grosse pression
fiscale lance une campagne un nouveau
tract c'est la première campagne de
l'année qui est il est temps de défendre
les classes moyennes ce tract sera
distribué dans l'ensemble des
fédérations qu'ils vont recevoir dès la
fin de semaine donc ce week-end des
opérations de tractage auront lieu dans
l'ensemble des fédérations
nous répondons de cette manière aux
préoccupations des français en faisant
preuve de constance depuis toujours
l'année dernière déjà nous avions fait
plusieurs opérations pour dénoncer à les
hausses de taxes les hausses de taxes
sur le carburant le matraquage fiscal
que subissaient les français les
retraités avec la hausse de la csg
également les familles donc nous
poursuivons à travers cette opération
cette défense des classes moyennes en
demandant de mettre fin aux gaspillages
de l'argent public qui va permettre de
faire peser moins d'impôts moins de
pression fiscale sur toutes les classes
moyennes qui en souffre terriblement
aujourd'hui donc les républicains font
preuve de constance
nous sommes toujours contre ces hausses
continue d'impôts contre cette pression
qui pèse toujours sur sur les mêmes et
nous sommes toujours au
près des préoccupations des français et
notamment les classes moyennes nous
demandons donc la réduction de la
pression fiscale la lutte contre le
gaspillage delà de la dépense publique
évidemment nous n'oublions pas les
retraités qui subissent de plein fouet
les décisions du gouvernement et qui ont
vu leur pouvoir d'achat a reculé comme
celui des familles donc c'est une
présence de plus de notre famille
politique sur ces sujets sur le terrain
ce terrain que ne connaît pas la
république en marche avec la force de
nos convictions avec la force de nos
propositions avec de la constance est
toujours au plus près de ce qui
préoccupe les français
l'objectif c'est d'installer et de
reconstruire notre famille politique en
tant qu alternative crédible face au mcs
ronis mkii et qui est en fait une somme
d'arrogance et d'opportunisme merci
beaucoup nous voudrions également saisir
l'occasion de ce point presse pour
réaffirmer notre attachement à ceux-ci
de l' équilibre en matière de
communication publique nous sommes en
effet assez étonné des one man show
successifs du président de la république
ce qui l'agitent d'ailleurs comme un
mantra pour conjurer le risque de la
crise en ayant souvent que la réalité du
terrain est plus forte que ses propres
interventions mais le monopole de la
parole présidentielle sur un grand
nombre
en tout cas en direct de médias en
information continue
non pas que les médias soit en cause
mais nous interroge tout de même et nous
nous permettons de formuler vis-à-vis du
csa des interrogations sur le respect de
l'équilibré de la parole publique
nous sommes dans un temps où il nous
semble que toutes les voix doivent
participer au rétablissement de l'ordre
républicain et nous voudrions surtout
que le csa veille scrupuleusement c'est
en tout cas ce que nous demandons ce
matin à ce que l'équilibré du temps de
parole soit respectée c'est une
condition sinequanone
de la démocratie et on ne pourrait pas
imaginer que un déséquilibre puisse
durer aussi longtemps donc des heures et
des heures d'interventions
présidentielles pose la question de
l'équilibré des temps de parole dans un
régime démocratique qui se respecte donc
nous sommes très soucieux de ce point et
nous interpellons le csa à cet égard
voilà mesdames messieurs ce que nous
voulions rappeler en préambule de ce
point presse et nous nous tenons à votre
disposition pour les questions que vous
auriez à nous poser bonjour pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez sur
l'agenda est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus si vous le pouvez
sur ce tour de france quand m laurent
wauquiez est ce que ce pourrait être
sous la forme de grands débats de
laurent wauquiez avec des français
comment ça va s'organiser
on va évidemment précisé
d'abord l'agenda en lui-même puisqu'on
vous adonner à la séquence qui va
pratiquement représenter deux semaines
l'idée de laurent wauquiez c'est d'aller
au contact des terrains non pas du
terrain non pas de se jeter à corps
perdu dans des exercices de grand messe
il y aura évidemment des moments public
je pense qu'il sera attaché à ce que nos
militants républicains qui sont partout
présents sur le terrain qui sont
directement concernés comme l'ensemble
des français par les événements en cours
souhaiteront également le voir pour voir
lui parler mais l'exercice auquel il se
prête c'est une rencontre avec
l'ensemble du terrain ce sont des
visites sur le terrain donc pas
simplement de grands en public mais
parfois des formes à un peu plus
restreint l'idée du président des
républicains
c'est de coller avec les réalités
d'interroger les français
outre ce qu'il connaît bien dans sa
propre région puisque vous savez qu'il a
l'habitude d'administrer au plus près du
terrain en se déplaçant régulièrement
mais c'est de le faire à l'échelle
nationale donc on aura des temps qui
sont vraiment des temps des changes
laurent wauquiez dans une position d'
écoute il tient absolument ça nourrit sa
propre réflexion et ça doit nourrir avec
d'autres instruments
la réflexion de républicains pour faire
face à la crise et tenter de s'en sortir
lydia vous a fait part toute à l'heure
des idées que nous
souhaitions propagé sur le terrain une
grande consultation militante a lieu
aujourd'hui mais là il va prendre le
pouls de tous les français
c'est exactement l'enjeu de ce grand
déplacement assez inédit dans l'histoire
de notre formation politique
en tout cas à cette échelle dans ce
format pour aller un peu plus loin les
républicains ont dit ont manifesté leur
intention de participer au grand débat
national
de quelle manière comptez-vous il
prendre par une grande consultation a
été un questionnaire a été envoyé à nos
militants qui vont pouvoir répondre nous
avons fait et depuis longtemps nous
faisons des propositions sur tous les
sujets que ce soit la dépense publique
comment la diminuer comment lutter
contre le gaspillage également de
l'argent public sur les questions de
sécurité également
donc c'est cette consultation ce
questionnaire a été envoyé à nos
militants et une contribution va être va
être apportée aux grands débats par par
le parti voilà dans les jours dans les
jours qui viennent pour en février cette
contribution sera apporté une question
évidemment sur les informations du
figaro est ce que vous confirmez que ce
sont bien trois noms qui seront soumis
demain au vote de la ceni et les trois
noms du figaro alors on va rien confirmé
du tout si votre consoeur as a
effectivement ce matin a publié un
article qui nous semble assez
circonstancié il n'en reste pas moins
que la commission nationale
d'investiture est souveraine qu'elle se
réunit demain et que nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer que elle n'est pas à son issue
une information à produire à l'intention
de l'ensemble des français donc à ce
stade et ce matin nous n'irons pas au
delà
désolé de nourrir cette frustration que
je lis sur vos visages mais nous
rendront ensemble demain la réunion de
la céni pour avoir l'ensemble des
précisions qui seront évidemment apporté
à son issue c'est pas sympa ça j'en ai
bien conscience
je vais on va être très méchant mais on
va effectivement vous avez raison on va
attendre la réunion de la céni de demain
et la laisser délibéré souverainement et
sereinement
c'est exactement la même réponse
je pense que l'idée peut au moins
rappeler ceci ça sera une façon j'espère
élégante de ne pas répondre à votre
question mais on a ans s'est emparé du
thème européen
les premiers vous rappeler que le
dernier conseil national des
républicains était consacrée à ce thème
donc c'est un sujet qui nous tient à
coeur et nous faisons totale confiance à
la ceni pour trouver la bonne équation
pour que le débat soit nourri et que nos
valeurs soient portées haut et fort par
l'ensemble des membres de la liste
réponse demain c'est tout bon pour vous
très bien merci en tout cas de votre
présence et à la semaine prochaine sans
aucun doute
merci